now that we're supercomputer experts
let's just build one so what are we
gonna need well first you're gonna need
two linux capable systems I highly
suggest you just buy the two raspberry
PI's to follow along identically with us
so there's no issues with setup and
software and all this kind of stuff
because what we're gonna doubt well at
least for sure the MPI that we're
downloading it's like super portable and
I'm not really sure how well it's gonna
work on just anything so anyway there's
there's that for sure but anyway
depending on what you have on hand if
you want to go the Raspberry Pi route
it'll probably only cost you like 80
bucks so it's a real cheap way to have a
have one so so - raspberry PI's they're
gonna cost you $35 to $40 each
you'll need power supplies for each pie
the pie if you buy it does not come with
anything but the board so the power
supply for the Raspberry Pi is a cell
phone charger I'm guessing you already
have one usually when you buy a cell
phone you get the charger with it I
don't know if they're stopping doing
that these days last cellphone I bought
was like two years ago so actually was
like three years ago mess old cell phone
anyway so a cell phone charger basically
it needs to have five volts in 750
million personally I bought a bunch of
these five volts 15 hundred milli amp
chargers since I have a bunch of PI's
and if say you're using a 750 million
and you plug in a USB keyboard a USB
mouse and/or usually what does it for me
is I plug in a I have this big 32
gigabytes thumb drive and I plug that
into them and they just die so so I need
that one 1500 and I'm pretty sure my old
charger was like a thousand milliamps
and it would still die when I would plug
that thing in but anyway
so there's that you'll need two of those
they're pretty cheap you can find them
on eBay - for that specific size or
specifications rather stinkin size
because the next thing you're gonna need
is two SD cards greater than 2 gigabytes
each in size again I just had these
laying around I'm guessing you guys do
too but you're going to need them next
you're going to need two x cat5 cables
to plug
to your router or modem I had these
laying around to for initial setup
you're gonna want an HDMI enabled
television and that cable an HDMI cable
and a USB keyboard you don't absolutely
need this stuff you can set up your pie
without any of this but it becomes a big
challenge and I'm not going to cover
that in this video
well actually it's not even mean this
none of that's gonna be in this video
but the series I won't be covering that
so that's really it hopefully most of
you guys just need to buy the 2 by 2
pies and you've got the rest of the
stuff if you're new to raspberry pies
you can do a lot of really really neat
things with them like robotics or you
can just use them as a computer or the
whole slew of other things even if you
don't keep them as a supercomputer
forever you can use them for all sorts
of fun activities a lot of people also
use them for media centers it's a really
cheap media center and it's also very
easy to repurpose them the operating
system and pretty much everything that
defines what that pie does for you is on
an SD card so you're gonna have your
supercomputer SD card media center SD
card robotics SD card etc you just plug
it in and you're ready to go with that
version so for now I'll just show my
setup for anybody that is curious I have
quite a few computers so I wind up
needing switches so it's just like an
Ethernet switch I bought this little
switch for $40 comes with five ports one
for the main connection to the router or
modem or whatever or another switch that
goes to the router and modem and it's
got four slots for four more devices
it's pretty nice for $40.00 small in the
casing is all metal definitely a good
buy not an affiliate or anything just
happy with it next up is this case I
really like this case I used to all the
PI's I would buy before would come with
like this plastic case and I really like
the case but it doesn't stack so this
case is pretty much built perfectly like
the PI fits in there perfectly like you
can turn it on its side and 7-1 like
fall out like there's little notches in
the bars and you like slip the corner of
the pint of those notches so it holds it
in place real well so it's never resting
on its bottom or anything like that yet
it's open air so it's really nice you
can plug all your peripheral peripherals
in
to it and all of that and you can keep
stacking pies up you can buy another you
know two of these things and stack them
on top of each other so real nice I will
put links to this stuff in the
description just in case people want it
again not an affiliate just a happy
customer finally well a few things one I
would like to point out this is purely
for learning purposes for two reasons
one I'm not responsible for anything you
do to your pie if you mess it up this is
in the exploration of education also
your raspberry pie does not make a very
good supercomputer node for most tasks
that supercomputers are used for instead
it just represents one of the cheapest
yet easiest ways to build a
supercomputer for extremely cheap
you're better off buying a nice
motherboard with like a 3-way SLI and
stacking of some epic GPUs getting like
fifteen to twenty teraflops for a total
set-up cost of like four thousand five
thousand dollars just for kicks to get
twenty teraflops you're gonna need to
buy sixty four thousand raspberry pies
so there's that lastly while the pie is
I keep saying lastly and finally guys I
got like a million of these anyways well
the pie is not the best option based on
like flops it should be noted that flops
are not really the sole determinant of a
computer's performance nor its value or
purpose right so there's a reason why a
CPU pushing 150g flops cost as much as a
GPU pushing three to four teraflops
there are different types of jobs in
questions so you can find new purposes
and purposes for the pie and also of
course a super computer pie so one
example would indeed actually be
robotics where you have a PI controlling
various parts of a robot which at its
core is a supercomputer responding to
environment variables so each PI allows
for eight default GPIO connections so
you can get pretty intense pretty quick
with a large amount of motors working
together as one giant system of
raspberry PI's this is really one
application of the raspberry probably
supercomputer that you really can't find
anywhere else you can't find like good
um ways to do this I mean the Arduino
maybe and the BeagleBone would probably
be a good one too but I mean these are
all like the same kind of like credit
card-sized computers that have GPIO pins
right or just IO pins so I would say the
PI is likely one of the cheapest options
so far probably the BeagleBone is a
superior supercomputer but for robotics
I might even choose the PI more I don't
know I've never used the BeagleBone I
just know it specifications so anyway
probably any combination of using
peripherals like so if you need
something that has USB it's powered by
USB or GPIO or any of that stuff this is
when the supercomputer made out of
raspberry PI's is going to be epic now
more on that later because we're
probably gonna use our pies for robotics
after the supercomputer setup and that's
kind of why I wanted to do
supercomputers first because you can
have these PI's working together as one
robot yet you can have like multiple
PI's right so you have to use the
supercomputing message passing interface
to do this so anyways we're on that
later just as a heads up that's my goal
but who knows I don't know if I'll
figure that out or not so hopefully this
topic is of interest to you all it
allows me to really bring a lot of the
concepts of my channel together at once
plus it's just really cool what you can
do with these technologies together and
you can build the cheapest supercomputer
you'll probably ever touch in your life
or if you've ever even seen a
supercomputer I've never even seen a
supercomputer until I built this one so
anyway at least not in person so that's
why he have looked forward to in the
coming videos as always thanks for
watching thanks for all the support the
subscriptions and until next time
my route we thought you liked me bug so
it's a real cheap way to have a happy so
so to expertise there